bonsoir martin schulz bonsoir merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
je voulais revenir sur les attentats qui
ont connu la ville de paris et de saint
denis
ces derniers jours ce sont les pires
attentats depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale les plus meurtriers
bernard cazeneuve et manuel valls ont
appelé le parlement européen à prendre
en compte leurs demandes de pnr le
passenger name record c'est-à-dire ce
fichier qui va permettre de voir quelles
passagers passent dans les vols intra
communautaire et donc de flécher un
petit peu les possibles terroristes
c'est une demande qui avait déjà été
fait après les attentats charlie-hebdo
cas ce qu'attend le parlement européen
pour valider ce pnr nous sommes déjà
depuis des mois en train de discuter pas
seulement pnrc aussi
réponse et rétention des données la
protection des données
ce qui pose problème c'est la protection
des données va cacher j'ai trois
directives de protection des données
propres projets de directives pour le
transfert des données des passagers des
lignes aériennes transatlantiques
internationaux et à l'intérieur de
l'union européenne c'est tout un paquet
les différentes
europol aussi sur la table nous sommes
en train de négocier ce paquet est bien
compréhensible que manuel valls bernard
cazeneuve font appel au parlement le
parlement normalement avec une vitesse
exceptionnelle répond à ses démons ceux
qui ont peu ce peu plus du mal de
répondre sont les états membres dont les
conseils des ministres
donc selon vous le ralentissement c'est
du haut conseil des ministres et aucun
passé ce n'est pas au ralentissement
nous sommes en train de légiférer mais
la collection des données ces deux une
cote est de 1 côtés de mme oda et
l'autre c'est comment utiliser les
données quel délai pour le retenir
et comme en échange les états membres de
l'union européenne ce qu'ils savent
entre eux et là on découverte que les
mêmes gouvernements qui font taper pas
les français mais les mêmes qui font
appel aux par le beau et collectionner
des données entre eux-mêmes n'échange
pas les mêmes données donc nous sommes
dans le processus de légiférer on va
jusqu'à la fin de l'année terminée j'ai
invité hier les différents des groupes
parlementaires ici au parlement pour
discuter avec eux les coordinateurs des
groupes parlementaires
et rapporteur et on va j'en suis sûr
jusqu'à la fin de l'année jusqu'à la fin
de l'année conclure vous disiez à
l'instant que les pays européens ont du
mal à échanger leurs données
on voit bien qu'il ya eu des ratés au
niveau du renseignement et de l'échangé
de renseignements entre les capitales
l'italie avait il ya quelques temps
proposé une agence européenne du
renseignement est ce que vous êtes sur
cette même ligne
je ne sais pas que ça c'est la solution
si c'était la solution oui mais
peut-être on n'a pas besoin une agence
traditionnelle il ainsi les aéroports le
registre si les états membres sont près
de fournir les institutions qui ont
besoin de données avec les données avec
la connaissance mais mon expérience avec
les services secrets c'est ils sont très
secret donc là on voit bien qu'il ya un
vrai problème global vont on propose
donc un pnr européen un meilleur
contrôle des armes à feu
la systématisation du contrôle aux
frontières un renforcement en fait de
schengen pourtant dans le cadre des
attentats de paris ce sont des européens
qui se sont attaqués à des européens
l'attak a été fomentée peut-être en
syrie mais a été commise depuis la
belgique vers la france est-ce que c'est
pas un petit peu petit bras est ce que
ça ne risque pas d'être insuffisant
comme réponse de ses présidents les
réponses sont nécessaires mais ça ne
suffit jamais ce qu'on a besoin c'est
que nous comme prénom comme vous l'avez
bien mentionné que les terroristes sont
des européens et il faut poser les
questions pourquoi elles sont devenues
terroriste qu'est ce qui se passe avec
les jeunes hommes et jeunes femmes qui
se radicalise pourquoi ça c'est à dire
il ne faut pas seulement
répondre à ce défi avec des mesures de
sécurité il faut aussi analyser les
raisons qui nous connaissons tous c'est
une sorte de sentiment d'exclusion alain
côté aussi un des privilégiés d'une
situation des privilégiés pardon des
jeunes dans les banlieues
si l'adresse dessine sur votre avenir
c'est déjà un et une exclusion en soit
dans la société donc temps des raisons
pour comprendre que les sources d'un
certain nombre de terrorisme sans chez
nous même ça ne peut pas nous empêcher
de comprendre que d'aller chez est une
force avec une brutalité volonté de tuer
son précédent vous disiez qu'il ne faut
pas avoir que des réponses sécuritaires
que pensez-vous de la mesure prise par
le gouvernement français et par françois
hollande de l'état d'urgence en france
parce que ce n'est pas quand on est au
niveau européen et quand on est garant
des textes et des libertés fondamentales
une forme de dépassement un petit peu du
droit quand je crois pas un président de
la république dans une situation comme
il est charlie hebdo en janvier
maintenant au mois de novembre
le bataclan et les restaurants avec
confronter avec le fait qu'il y à une
bande de terroristes qui ne vise plus un
groupe spécial ou des représentants de
l'état de la société d'émulation sa
population pour intimider n'a aucune
autre possibilité que répondre avec la
fermeté qui est exprimé par l'état
d'urgence et moi je suis a besoin de
manger de connaître très bien
franchement au long de cet homme qui a
toujours défendu les valeurs
fondamentales individuelles les droits
individuels
je crois que l'état d'urgence est dans
les mains d'un homme absolument
responsable en ce qui concerne les
droits des françaises et des français
on a constaté durant l' enquête que des
passeports
de réfugiés syriens auraient été
utilisés par certains terroristes
notamment ceux qui ceux qui ont fait
usage de bombes près du stade de france
à saint-denis
certains pointent du coup la
responsabilité de la grèce de la turquie
et donc la possibilité pour les tirs
terroristes d'utiliser le chemin des
migrants des réfugiés pour entrer en
europe est ce que vous y croyez
non et je le fis de toujours de ces gens
qui ont le lendemain d'un attentat comme
celui là déjà tous les conclusions qu'il
n'y a pas de selon vous de terroristes
potentiels dans les réfugiés qui
accélère à un pas après l'autre
tout d'abord vous m'avez posé cette
question sur les passeports là un moment
je reste là parce que c'est complètement
disparu si vous regardez ce niaisement
les publications personne n'en parle
mais le lendemain de l'attentât et de la
rue de la découverte tout le monde a
tout de suite dit à ce qu'est ce qu'il y
avait avec ceux avec ce passeport
pourquoi personne n'en parle aujourd'hui
par trois raisons premièrement les
experts tout de suite on dit c'est
peut-être peut-être aussi une trace
fraudeuse parce que le passeport était
enregistrée en grèce et en serbie en
même temps fatigué un trafic des faux
pas voilà peut-être info 2
un terroriste qui s'explose lui même et
qui a son passeport avec lui la carte
d'identité donne immédiatement aux
services de sécurité le réseau auquel il
appartient alors normalement ils ne
s'exposent pas on sait s'identifiant
automatiquement ça c'était exceptionnel
oui il y as peut-être parmi les huit
cent mille réfugiés aussi des gens qui
étaient
très infiltrée mais nous avons eu en
allemagne et par exemple une centaine de
cars d'allégations où les gens ont dit
il faut regarder
aucun cas cette épreuve est donc pas
exclue mais aussi par brevet est ce que
vous diriez comme certains ont pointé en
fait depuis ces derniers jours que
schengen est un échec
donc chacun n'a pas été que certains
éléments de la libre circulation dans
notre marché commun et j'écoute ça mais
contrôler la frontière comme ça se passe
ici à strasbourg actuellement dans la
loi n'y ai rien à faire rétablir les
contrôles aux frontières avant la cap 21
non pas seulement ça c'est aussi
admissibles dans le cadre de sheng vient
d exception des cas et c'est
exceptionnel et ceux qui se plaisent ce
qui s'est passé à paris c'est un cas
exceptionnel mais il faut à l'autre côté
aussi comprendre que la libre
circulation des marchandises des
capitaux des services et des personnes
sondées cap liberté de marché intérieur
et si vous par exemple transporter les
marchandises ou des services à
l'intérieur de l'union européenne
ça ne fonctionne pas sans la libre
circulation des personnes
moi j'habite à côté d'une frontière sur
le triangle maastricht liège aix la
chapelle l'allemagne les pays bas et la
belgique des deux grands plus grand port
en europe
anvers et rotterdam tous les
marchandises qui viennent de là-bas
elles sont transportées vers les 82
millions allemands qui les consomment
passe par aix la chapelle si vous fermez
là les frontières pour les citoyens et
pour les camions il dure 24 heures et à
stuttgart la production des mercedes est
terminée parce que le transport c'est
just in time où les grands supermarchés
n'ont plus de marchandises donc rétabli
des conserves est oublié les cats ont
des nids des conserves ni des poissons
frais qui viennent aussi de là bas ça
veut dire quoi
on arrête vous parce que vous êtes une
personnalité avec le droit de libre
échange
dans une voiture et avec tes cheveux
frisés des heureux des yeux bras on vous
avez dit madame votre passeport mais les
camions transportés par votre frère peut
passer ça c'est en europe qui dure 24
heures et les mêmes gens qui insistent
de l'arrêt rétablissement des contrôles
aux frontières vont se révolter parce
qu'ils n'ont pas envie de passer la
moitié de leur vie dans un bouchon
je comprends bien maintenant quand on
dit qu'il faut rétablir les contrôles
aux frontières extérieures de l'europe
c'est que on a peut-être été trop loin
dans ce manque de contrôle quand on a
des terroristes qui sont en capacité
d'aller chargé des armes en espagne de
remonter toute l'europe de passer par la
belgique et de redescendre en france on
a aussi échoué quelque part l'extérieur
ça c'est clair
la protection des frontières extérieures
c'est un des beaux arts de l'union
européenne dans les mains des états
membres
nous avons donné comme souvent une
responsabilité à l'union une tâche
communautaire protection des frontières
extérieures même pas dans les mains de
monsieur juncker ou de monsieur schulz
ou de monsieur tous dans les mains du
gouvernement grec
ton ami du gouvernement espagnol le
gouvernement bulgare du gouvernement
polonais pour protéger les frontières
extérieures de l'union européenne et si
ça ne fonctionne pas parce que pas tous
ces gouvernements mais quelques de ce
gouvernement incapable de protéger les
frontières ou ne veulent pas on blâme
ensuite l'union alors ce qui nous
propage priorité pour les solutions
nationaux comme cette femme qui veut
devenir président de la france qui siège
ici au parlement nous raconte sa
toujours l'europe des nations tout
d'abord versé voilà l'europe des nations
que nous voyons agir dans la protection
des frontières extérieures
l'échec potentiel du contrôle aux
frontières extérieures c'est l'échec des
nations a donc garde pas l'échec des
nations c'est pas l'échec de nation
c'est l'échec d'un système erronée on ne
peut pas
donner une responsabilité à une
communauté ensuite ça soumettre sous les
réserves en permanence des prérogatives
nationales
ça ne fonctionne pas dernière question
monsieur le président la turquie a
aujourd'hui abattue en avion russe qui a
violé son espace aérien
est-ce qu'on est dans une escalade du
conflit en syrie j'espère nos parce
qu'on a besoin soit la turquie et la
russie pour battre d'âge donc que ce que
nous avons besoin pour une coalition
contre ces assassins sont maintenant
dans une telle situation
c'est lamentable j'espère beaucoup qu'on
va trouver une solution diplomatique
pour cet incident merci beaucoup
monsieur le président merci